greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
now let's talk about a person that they
tell me is of some importance Jesus
who is this of Nazareth you speak of
they tell me that he is the savior and
supposed to bring peace to this world
bang-up job
who is this Paul where is he I see his
image everywhere yet I do not see him
shy isn't he certainly he knows that he
cannot compete against the power
absolved you honor him for Christmas
when clearly you should be honoring me
people talk about how impressed they are
that he was born in a simple humble
manger well I was born in a lava pit on
the fiery surface of Krypton take that
of Nazareth it's totally boss they say
that he can perform miracles
I can shoot lasers for my eyes I can
also walk on water in fact the more I
think about this Jesus fellows probably
just a lost Kryptonian who crash-landed
on your planet he came down did some
magic tricks and you treated him as your
Lord and Savior what about me whores all
nobody brought me shiny medals perfume
when a bombing agent that's supposed to
preserve my corpse I like myrrh
I like it a lot in fact I use it as my
daily deodorant it's bitter sting makes
humans eyes water now you might be
asking the question if he was a
Kryptonian how did he ascend into heaven
we can fly if I was to tell you I'm the
son of god I'm gonna burn to the bottom
of the earth I can do that very easily
watch I have plundered this ancient
Buddhist bust from the temples of Tibet
in my spare five seconds but see Jesus
treasure sighs Jesus of Nazareth his
real name was probably Joe why would you
even celebrate such a person it sounds
like all he did was get nailed to a tree
I commanded armies and I'm still around
he could even punch out a few dusty
Romans I'm not dying for your sins
you'll die for mine clearly I'm the more
qualified Lord and Savior and thus
inácio dresser black goes with any final
summer Jesus does not belong if there's
only in People's Republic of Houston he
belongs in the Kryptonian cell for
making people believe that you
the son of God when in reality he was
most likely a janitor one of our
mid-level office buildings I knew it
oops if we're going to get duped get to
by me there is no substitution for salt
say no to God
yes dissolve this is General Zod and you
will all kneel before me okay